hello in this video we will study about
the bilirubin metabolism the bilirubin
metabolism begins with the red blood
cells which have a lifespan of
approximately 120 days and after they
complete their life cycle they are
destroyed in organs like the spleen and
the liver which contain numerous
macrophages so it releases the
hemoglobin within the red blood cells
the hemoglobin is then split into the
heme component and the globin component
the globin is further converted into the
amino acids and utilized in the body the
heme component is then converted into
the iron and the billa verdun and this
reaction is catalyzed by the enzyme heme
oxygenase in the next step the pili
burden is converted into the yellow
compound the pill Aruban and this
reaction is catalyzed by the enzyme pili
Verde reductase this bilirubin so formed
is it in the unconjugated form which is
not the water soluble form so it
requires albumin for its transport to
the liver in the liver the bilirubin is
converted into the conjugated form which
is the water soluble form of the
bilirubin and this reaction takes place
by the combination of glucuronic acid
with unconjugated bilirubin it is then
transported through the biliary channels
into the duodenum and through the door
denim it reaches the colon in the colon
the bilirubin is acted upon by number of
microorganisms and is converted into
urobilinogen and stir cover unison
majority of these compounds are excreted
in the feces in the form of stucco
bailan which imparts the yellow color to
the faeces but 10 to 15% of these
compounds are reabsorbed into the blood
and some part of that reaches the liver
and this is known as the anterior
hepatic circulation a few percentage of
the reabsorbed compounds reach the
kidney
and they are excreted in the urine in
the form of euro bailan so this was a
brief overview of the bilirubin
metabolism I hope you find this video
useful make sure to subscribe to our
channel for further videos and also like
our Facebook page for upcoming
notifications thank you so much for
watching